bienvenue dans ce culture première et
bonsoir tout d'abord avec nous ce sort
qu'elle pour sa chronique habituel au
sommaire ce soir de la danse de rue dans
les hauts de la réunion à la plaine des
cafres une mise en scène orchestrée par
la compagnie artefact qui récidive
mélissa planté nous en dira plus autre
invité béatrice le guen de l'association
chao la réunion avec elle y sera
question du 6e festival du film italien
il s'agit plus exactement de ces sacrés
grand acteur italien des monstres ap
enfin photographe pour parler d'un pays
qu'il a visité plusieurs fois la chine
carte google réunionnais d'adoption
exposé à l'artothèque l'expo s'appelle
machine rouge
la mise en ondes est assurée par vincent
châu acb l'émission est à suivre sur le
site de la première est ce notre chaîne
youtube culture première jean-paul medad
nous retrouvons gaël bonjour quel alors
pour tronic demande elle est ce soir
c'est cannes et les femmes et alors
pourquoi ce thème est bien ce thème
jean-paul pour deux raisons très simples
première raison c'est qu'on est en plein
festival de cannes jusqu'à samedi
et puis cadets les femmes parce que
cette année qu'at elle fait bien plus
que son cinéma si je puis dire
en effet elle fait sa petite révolution
révolution féminine et féministe surtout
là on est une édition du festival de
cannes qui s'inscrit dans un contexte un
peu particulier hélas elle vient juste
après laffaire 20h taille et les
mouvements de dénonciation de
harcèlement et de violences sexuelles
avec life tag nitoo et balances ton port
et ce contexte fait que sans être
radicalement différent des éditions
précédentes avec ce 71e festival cannes
a fait quelques petits progrès pour
prendre un virage un peu plus féministe
et ça c'est encourageant parce que
jusque-là qu'un était avant tout un
festival hyper masculin l'écrasante
majorité des présidents du jury des
réalisateurs des producteurs et des
lauréats de la palme d'or étaient et des
zones mais cette année calmer un peu
plus les femmes à l'honneur
déjà jean paul cette année ce n'est pas
un mais une présidente du jury quels
blanchette c'est extraordinaire quand on
pense que dans toute l'histoire du
festival qui a quand même commencé en
1946 il n'y a eu que dix femmes sur une
soixantaine d'hommes qui ont reçu ce
privilège
autre nouveauté de cette année a salué
également le jury de la compétition
officielle
elle est majoritairement féminin yes il
ya une montée de marches un peu spécial
cette année
exact jean-paul c'était samedi dernier
une montée des marches 100% féminine 80
de femmes ont monté ensemble les marches
du palais pour revendiquer l'égalité des
salaires et une véritable parité pardon
dans l'industrie du cinéma
moi j'ai trouvé ça audacieux
sensationnel mais surtout légitime quand
on sait que par exemple
deux femmes seulement ont obtenu la
palme d'or en 70 festival la première
c'est jane campion pour la leçon de
piano en 93 et puis il a eu agnès varda
qui a eu une palme d'honneur et j'en
profite d'ailleurs pour inviter les
auditeurs cette semaine à revoir la
leçon de piano de campion par exemple ou
bien un film de verdun alors sinon pour
cette édition 2010 8 cannes il ya plus
de réalisatrice que d'habitude en
compétition au non loin de là c'est en
ce sens aussi que cannes et les femmes
c'est encore une histoire à écrire sur
les 21 films en compétition il y en a
que trois élèves qui ont été réalisés
par des femmes
et là j'ai eu envie de vous parler de
deux de ses films donc en sélection
officielle
ce sont mes coups de coeur le premier
c'est capharnaüm de la libanaise nadine
labaki
c'est l'histoire d'un garçon de 12 ans
qui intente un procès à ses parents pour
lui avoir donné la vie tenez vous bien
l'intrigué dramatique certes mais
absolument génial là c'est le thème de
l'enfance maltraitée et des mauvais
parents qui m'a plu dans ce film est le
second film c'est les filles du soleil
de la française ewa hudson
il pourrait bien avoir la palme d'or ce
film là c'est l'histoire d'un groupe de
combattants kurdes qui vont affronter
des soldats de neige et elles ont une
devise la femme la vie la liberté
ça prouve que la devise du festival de
cannes cette année donc un festival qui
hélas est toujours peu féminin mais un
peu plus féministe voilà c'était notre
petit détour par la croisette
en attendant la remise des prisonniers
merci
culture première de la danse avec vous
mais 10 ha plantés bonsoir bon ça à mes
débuts face du micro des douanes au port
d'el eulma face de vous parce que sinon
bah là bravo merci
nous allons parler donc de rouve la case
cinquième édition et cela se passe à la
plaine des cafres cette année au 23e km
avant se tait ou alors où la case séné
en 2013 sur la commune de saint paul on
a fait quatre éditions donc à rue
jacques haut à savannah un carrosse et à
barrage le dernier est donc depuis cette
année en pour 2018 on s'exporte dans les
eaux du sud de l'île alors fait une
histoire qui a commencé donc il ya à peu
près quatre ans et ça il ya quatre ans
c'est la rencontre entre votre
association move ap
et céline amato alors c'est un concept
qui est original nous ont un peu plus
parce que ça se passe chez les gens tout
à fait en fait au départ
donc moi je suis organisatrice du
festival dans ce pays ont fait ont
programmé des méthodes de danse dans la
rue et en fait j'ai eu envie d'aller
plus loin nous dire pourquoi pas
programmer directement des spectacles
chez l'habitant à ce moment là j'ai fait
appel à céline amato et à partir de là
on a commencé
surtout elle a élaboré à faire évoluer
le concept donc oui ça a amené de la
danse directement dans la cour des gens
alors ce concept c'est un concept unique
ou alors il existe un peu partout ici ou
ailleurs alors évidemment il est l art à
la réunion il ya eu du du théâtre chez
l'habitant décidé la musique chez
l'habitant et la danse habitants on est
les premiers
il est à la réunion mais ce qui existe
ailleurs alors oui puisqu'on à la base
on s'était inspiré de
d'une chorégraphe suisse s'appelle
nicole teulière qui faisait l de la
danse dans les hlm où les gens
regardaient depuis très longtemps avec
des jumelles prend évidemment le concept
à la réunion et aucun sens et non qu'on
se dit bayrou la case dans les cases
director comment ça se passe que les
gens comment les gens nous accueillent
thil est ce que doivent être surpris au
départ non alors en fait donc évidemment
ça se passe comme ça d'abord il faut
qu'on fasse du porte à porte ont déjà on
décide d'un quartier aussi dans quel
quartier m'apprendre évidemment prend un
quartier l'on vous choisissez ben on va
dans les quartiers où l'offre culturelle
ne va pas bien voilà donc un troisième
vote faussé cette fois ci le 23e donc
déjà le quartier a pris donc on fait du
porte à porte donc bonjour association
mova compagnie artefact un ado moon est
ce qu'on pourrait venir chez vous faire
un spectacle de danse est là et ben en
fait oui les gens disent oui et très
étonnamment c'est souvent les seniors
les cram qui nous ouvre le plus le plus
facilement les portes ça c'est
incroyable
alors justement est-ce que les gramounes
participa dans ceux de gaz
ben en fait évidemment il participe
parce que comme je vous dis c'est les
premiers à ouvrir leurs portes a à nous
offrir le café à discuter à nous mettre
en contact avec d'autres personnes en
quartiers c'est vraiment d'aider des
personnes ressources qui qui qui lance
la cette bonne humeur pour pour monter
ce projet là donc après souvent quelques
fois on a eu des cram ans qui ont dansé
avec nous mais souvent c'est un petit
peu mais là et tout donc non il faut
faire part préfère pas mais par contre
ils sont là et ouvrent leur maison ils
nous reçoivent
et vous quand même une maison de la
place une varangue départ en fait on
une arrière-cour on va choisir on va
prendre place évidemment mais des fois
c'est sûr les spectacles de danse ça
peut être un solo un duo un trio ils
peuvent être 10 on s'en va on s'adapte
en fonction du lieu du lieu ça c'est le
travail de céline amato alors là vous
avez trouvé un endroit plus grand ou pas
on a un peu de tout alors on a on a des
maisons prenante on a vraiment le tout
et on a même des espaces publics
puisqu'en fait on on aime bien comme on
aime bien mener la danse soit ne va pas
donc là par exemple cette année on a
cette maison et on a trois espaces
publics
donc on a devant le parvis de l'église
du 23e sur un petit pont dans une
résidence neuve un petit pont en bois ou
dans quelques les voitures qui passent
que toujours du petit pont en bois et
dans cette année on fait dans une ravine
dans une revue dont on a besoin
d'emmener en haleine emmener un piano à
mafate
pourquoi pas au hockey et dont je
suppose qu il a des gens qui dansent il
ya des amateurs il ya des des gens qui
habitent le quartier qui viennent qui
participait il ya des professionnels
comment ça se passe en fait donc le
projet rouve la cadence l'habitant ont
fait une audition quelqu'un parce que le
projet on l'a commencée en avant bien
avant et c'est un long projet jeu par
jour est l'occasion de développer ce que
ce qui prouve la case la résidence
artistes de territoire mais roulhac
assad dans chaque habitant ont fait une
ambition régionale tous types de danse
tous types de danseurs pas de
professionnels des amateurs et là vient
de se présenter
des jeunes des moins jeunes des vraiment
variété chorégraphique non dans ce qu'on
veut ce que l'on veut mais on vient avec
une proposition
là on fait une audition mais la vérité
c'est qu'on prend tout mon chef m'a bon
nombreux alors mal à cette année une
vingtaine de danseurs et en fait donc ça
c'est tout le tout l'art de céline amato
qui auraient dû être présents que ce
soit malheureusement elle est prise elle
est prise elle est reprise et donc elles
sont celles à son secret de chorégraphe
elle arrive à mélanger les genres dont
qu'ils se présentent avec leur groupe
mais du flamenco qui arrive un petit
groupe on a un groupe de danse africaine
un groupe de danse théâtre eh ben elle
avait mélangé les genres donc dans un
spectacle qu'on va se retrouver avec du
flamenco la danse contemporaine ou alors
du maloya avec un n échassiers orale
prendre les chansons shaker met tout
dedans et ce goût elle arriverait
quelque chose d'original
alors comment comment réagissent les
gens va en tout cas vous avez une
expérience puisqu'il ya déjà quinze
états j'adore il kiffe grave le plus
grave oui oui non non c c'est en fait
s'il ya une magie le jour la restitution
de ce projet il y avait le 2 juin de
juin elle appelle les quatre vingt trois
alors qu'est-ce qui vous revenez d'année
prochaine ou quoi quand ils ont vécu
cette expérience mais c'est bien pour ça
que je parle de la suite du projet parce
qu'en fait c'est qu'est ce qui se passe
après pourquoi enfin voila c'est
toujours là et cette année on a fait un
peu à l inverse c'est à dire que on à la
réception finale qui le 2 juin
mais avant ça on a passé dix semaines
dans le quartier à faire d'autres choses
encore
alors donc une résidence artistique de
territoires déjà ça ce sont des
partenariats
on a eu la belle entre guillemets mumble
territoire résidence artistique de
territoire carla bayle qui vient de la
région réunion et des dugal grand sud
on travaille avec la commune du temps du
golf du conseil général non non non le
gall ce sont les fonds européens avaient
cruellement défaut d'accord ok oui sa
célèbre alaoui et barbare de la culture
donc grâce à ces financements
parce que ce sont les opportunités de
financement on a installé donc dix
semaines de résidence dans le quartier
ça veut dire que on a pensé le projet
pour toucher différents publics les
enfants on est allé dans l'école
élémentaire
enfin moi non c'est une âme à tous
céline amato ses invités ils sont allés
dans l'école élémentaire pour travailler
autour d'un et spectacle de la compagnie
pour travailler avec les élèves
directement et du coup au pays des
hormones voilà vous faites pas rire à
chaque fois on est allé au collège
autour d'un spectacle
ils sont intervenus nous allécher les
gran moun on est allégé les gramounes
on est allé dans la rue on est allé dans
les associations et au fur et à mesure
en fait donc là on se sent vraiment la
peine non détaillées tout mais je salue
l'appel
on n'a jamais la radio
mais en fait l'idée c'était de
rencontrer les gens d'installer une
présence artistique de leur faire
découvrir les nouvelles disciplines
parce que le coeur du projet c'est la
danse mais on a aussi amené du street
art
alors justement attendait une belle
perche et cette année vous avez dû
street patrimoine du tricot graffitis et
de l'artiste et réactif
alors voilà ça c'est voilà alors dixit
céline amato la chorégraphe qui est
directrice artistique du projet alors
donc le street art patrimoine où aller
c'est fait les vieux alors c'est pas que
les vieux le stade pas le site reatard
patrimoine on le fait avec une artiste
qui s'appelle marie julie gascon et qui
depuis plusieurs week-ends va rencontrer
les familles ressources du quartier pour
être faire des portraits sur eux donc ça
va à faire des enregistrements qui vont
et après dont céline va se servir dans
les spectacles des portraits des photos
et du texte c'est pas innocente ou
sobres bah c'est qu'on fait revivre la
mémoire il ya tout un ensemble
oui c'est un projet qui est qui est
qu'ils en aient enfin qui travaillent
autour l'échangé de la proximité
alors voir d'autres non donc parce
qu'après ces portraits vont être le jour
de la restitution vont être dans le dans
le parcours on va on va les retrouver
dans le parcours le casque ou les
abricots graphique très beaux graphismes
alors ça c'est une idée un petit peu
folle vous connaissez le tricot oui bien
sûr micro futur et ben en fait l'idée
c'est d'aller à billes un espace public
donc on a rencontré oui oui on est parti
rencontrer les différentes associations
du quartier du 23e et du 27e qui
commence à cri très coté tricoter
tricoter tricoter donc céline amato qui
en plus cette chorégraphe leur apprend à
tricoter en fallait déjà que ça tricote
évidemment et en fait on va appuyer un
espace public du quartier du tricot
avait fait froid au 23e bon aller en bus
rapidement alors interactif alors l'air
interactif se trouve que c'était un
laboratoire de recherche dans le cas de
la résidence artistes de territoire
l'idée c'est d'installer une présence
artistique mais aussi que l'artiste qui
est donc céline hémato la compagnie
artefact travaille aussi sur sur sa
création
à venir donc l'art interactive sait
comment au milieu de l'espace public
on va installer quelque chose qui va
attirer le public pour eux c'est dur
c'est là où elles devraient être là ça
c'est devant le collège en gros c'est
comme on va créer des échanges avec le
public
par exemple je sais pas quand j'essaie
de voleurs ont piégé un petit peu plus
fournie que là on est 12e rang alors par
exemple par exemple au sol on commence à
écrire des phrases et des questions et
les gens passent dans la rue et jouer
parce que ce qu'est ce que c'est ou
alors à eau sur le le bon moment de
sortir
c'est pourquoi si haut l arrêt bus on
met une balançoire ça interpelle on a
lié des choses qu'on n'a pas pu faire
malheureusement parce que des fois dans
ce type de projet les artistes ils vont
un petit peu plus vite que les mairies
et donc des gens en fait on demande
quelque chose et on demande des choses
qui où il faut du temps pour que les
gens comprennent on veut aller ils ont
un petit peu des fois un petit peu plus
frileux passons nous demandons qu'il ya
des choses qu'on n'a pas pu faire aussi
je pense que ce que vous faites là ça va
certainement intéresser car le google
parce que vu ce qu'il a déjà réalisé par
le passé peut-être qu'il viendra chez
vous et oui il fait des photos de lui en
bien en tous les cas restitution le 2
juin tout le monde peut venir voir
évidemment c'est gratuit donc on a une
page facebook qui s'appelle rouve la
casse donc rouvellat kcr aux uv elle a
et casques à az est donc là sur la page
facebook et à toutes les informations il
ya un événement on s'inscrit et ensuite
on convient le au 23e km de la plaine
des cafres à la salle des fêtes du 23e à
13 heures grand maximum jusqu'à 13h à
13h30 ça commence et là on donnera en
public un plan qui lui permettra d'aller
découvrir les neuf propositions de danse
dans le quartier merci
mais les ça plante et mélisande mais les
entendants j'écris mélissa mélisande
planté de l'association au move arte
nova mouvement move à merci
qui sont venus déjà oublié le temps des
malades hambourg et
ne tentez de à savoir comment
oubliés ses heures qui doit parfois à
court de quoi le corps
dans la même petite taille
[Musique]
moi je t'offrirai
rénové
oui on le paie cash
je pense que la tienne jusqu'à prémaman
choco
[Musique]
je ferai de même pour mon sort
beaumont
tous
[Musique]
ne me quitte pas
non
[Musique]
d'habitude
je tends vite fait
des mots en santé que tu t'en ben moi je
te parle le plus
des césar
qu'ils ont
toutefois le club
j'adore
l'histoire ne sont pas bons
culture première et 18h33 bonsoir
maîtrise le gua vous êtes vous êtes
d'avis président vous êtes membre de
l'association chao raynaud
vice-président du 6ème festival du film
italien nommé à l'insu de mon plein gré
présidente
mais c'est pas grave c'est vrai mais
vous l'êtes quand même donc c'est un
festival du film italien du 24 mai au
1er juin c'est au plaza sein de nîmes le
thème seller sacré monstre il y aura lui
film
ils sont pour la plupart en version
originale sous qu'ils sont tous en
version originale sauf le film destiné
aux scolaires de la ville basse ou
titres et sous-titrés
alors vous vous adressez uniquement aux
italiens pas du tout alors dont ça on
s'adresse à tous les cinéphiles de la
réunion qui n'ont pas l'occasion de voir
des films parfois anciens il n'y a pas
de cinéma d'art et d'essai ces films ne
sont quasiment plus diffusés sur les
grandes télévisions ou dans les cinémas
et on se rend compte qu'il y à un public
désireux de revoir des films anciens de
qualité italien puisque nous sommes
l'association de chiens aux réunions
mais ne nous ne tournons pas toujours
vers le passé nous avons le projet de
voir bientôt le cinéma du 21e siècle en
italie aussi alors je regarde le manque
du conseil d'administration il n'a pas
beaucoup d'italiens l'intérieur à
monsieur mentionne et qui est notre
président arias que lui la non il ya que
lui parce que massoni ces corses le gua
je ne pense pas que ça soit je suis
d'origine italienne pendant son perdre
ma première voilà ma maman d'origine
piémontaise
voilà arman en caratini aussi vous êtes
ouhlala faut faire attention à vous la
familia la famille et puis y'a des mares
joe dimaggio notre professeur de dessin
magnifique qui a réussi à me faire
peindre
vous imaginez vous êtes une pointeuse
une peinture est une pâte aura sous ses
yeux
mais ce n'est pas très bien alors des
films que vous avez choisi bon ce sont
des films dont moody's et qui sont quand
même relativement ancien il date à peu
près tous des années 70 ça à quelqu'un a
quelque chose sauf l'amour
et le chat qui est donc en version
française pour les scolaires qui donc le
film est donc de 98 celui là il est
enfoncé et les deux enzo dahalo que je
veux pas hot dogs et un totalisateur
italien spécialiste des films
d'animation qui est relativement connu
qui a fait un très beau pinocchio qui a
fait aussi un d'autres je sais que nous
avons passé déjà plusieurs fois le
pinocchio et la mouette et le chat nous
l'avons déjà proposé il ya fort
longtemps
c'est un très beau documentaire dessin
animé par don qui est ma langue a
fourché involontairement parce que les
sujets que la mouette et le chat traite
sont des sujets de documentaires
d'actualité le pétrole le les animaux
qui meurent englués dans le pétrole la
solidarité entre animaux le chat va
protéger l'oeuvre de la mouette qui va
mourir dans le pétrole et le loiseau va
aider les chats lutter contre les rangs
gros faudra pas changé depuis 20 ans
mais voilà c'est formidable c'est la
société humaine expliqué aux enfants à
travers les animaux alors il ya des aura
donné les titres de films il ya les
nouveaux monstres dont we had mario
monicelli dino risi et ettore scola pain
chocolat vous avez lucky luciano le
signe de vénus la grande guerre nous
sommes tant aimés d'ettore scola
la mouette et le chant vient d'en parler
et une journée particulière d'ettore
scola
vous l'aimez vraiment on voulait mais
tori scola deux fois deux fois et en cas
de nouveaux monstres et 3 il a participé
au nouveau monde mais vous savez ces
réalisateurs qui sont ici citer sont les
grands réalisateurs de cette période
comme les acteurs sans les grands
acteurs nous avons voulu voir ces grands
acteurs que nous avons appelée de
sacrément sans eux il n'y aurait pas eu
ces grands réalisateurs ne rêvons pas
c'est une coopération très étroite
les uns ont fait les autres et vice
versa beaucoup de morts à l'intérieur en
branle doctorow alors nous avons choisi
lé nous étions précurseurs gaël l'an
passé puisque les avions notre 5e
festival du film italien qui était
intitulé les bellissime les plus belles
et les plus grandes
l'italienne est donc nous avons fait le
pendant nous ne pouvions pas laisser la
gente masculine à l'écart et dont nous
avons fait cette reste ival consacrée
aux grands acteurs de sacré monstre lead
léman bleu apparaît mais sacré parce
qu'ils ont leur caractère
ils sont aussi les représentants de tout
ce cinéma italien y va d depuis le néo
réalisme jusqu'à la fin de la comédie à
l'italienne à la fin des années 70 77
nous nous sommes tant aimés c'est la fin
de la grande comédie
alors justement le cinéma italien
aujourd'hui on peut on en parle on en a
plus beaucoup parler dans les années
80-90 effectivement jusqu'en 2000
à part les westerns spaghetti et mais
qui sont très beau il a bon la brute et
le truand
mon nom est personne jura et nous le
cinéma italien revit avec de nouveaux
réalisateurs et nous avons le projet
venger enfin peut-être en novembre parce
que nous avons souvent en novembre mini
festival avec un invité et nous avons le
projet de faire un mini festival
consacré au cinéma du 21e siècle dont
les films extrêmement récent parce que
c'est reparti il y à de grands
réalisateurs qui sont apparus depuis les
années 2010 alors bon il ya le film les
festivals donc au plaza les films en
général à 18h30 heure trente deux fois
parce que nous avons la chance de voir
monsieur tu roulais tropiques harmonie
qui depuis trois ans participent à nos
festivals et nous joue des musiques de
films
nino rota cette année nous avons
beaucoup de plusieurs films avec dalle
de travail à un outil qui a fait la
musique de film de nous nous sommes tant
aimés et d'autres films est bon le
connais moi et pourtant c'est un grand
musicien donc tropiques harmonie se
joint à nous et nous les remercions pour
leur présence alors autour de cela n'y a
pas il n'ya pas qu'eux donc des films la
gastronomie il y a
des expositions alors nous avons eu ce
matin la presse est venue une exposit le
vernissage de l'exposition de peinture
de notre club de ta dessins et peintures
de ciao réunion qui est animée par
monsieur françois di maggio dont nous
parlions tout à l'heure et ce club c'est
enfin cette secours de peinture s'est
créée en novembre et nous sommes ravis
de pouvoir présenter nos heures au siège
social au giardino dit à lloret la case
l'heure combien d'oeuvres nombreux au
les quatre murs sont couverts de
chefs-d'oeuvre je pense que dans cent
ans se battra pour avoir le premier
programme expositions vont offrir avant
tout sa deuxième cela rejoint je suis
sûr voir et je pose ici
puis il ya le reste on suit pas l'europe
à cette histoire
enfin les restaurants italiens du centre
de saint-denis savoir giardino
d'italiens qui nous héberge la grande
italia rue alexis de villeneuve les
militaires aného également donc et
l'épicerie qui est à la bretagne
pas très loin de chez vous oui oui ma
famille fabrizi dont on a fait de la pub
là ce soir à eybens écoutez vous m'avez
posé la question à les a lésés
continuant que les restaurants italiens
les épiceries italienne nous soutiennent
et viennent participer à notre festival
donc ils vont exposer des choses ils en
vendent dans le hall du festival
certains produits et puis il propose des
plats ou sicilien où sarde où il donna
de la région de naples pour le troisième
restaurant que je ne citerai pas alors
faites-nous saliver un mois parce que un
des plats qui viennent de sardaigne
c'est ça le side moi ce que j'en dis bah
oui bien vous avez du poisson le poulpe
aussi le poulpe est très apprécié en
italie du sud et avoir ils redoublent en
brousse pour aia du lambrusco de madame
ben ali porte cher
[Musique]
d'accord la bonne nourriture italienne
beaucoup de belles patte du sorgho du
jeu du si la sauce italienne arrabiata
on m'avait 2 mais vous êtes le bienvenu
elle aussi c'est très gentil mais vous
appelez bienvenus alors donc on rappelle
que ça commence donc le 24 mai jusqu'au
1er juin
et ça au plaza et ça commence donc par
quel film happy meal auxerre commence
par les nouveaux mots ce qu'est la suite
des monstres des années 60 les nouveaux
mans ce sont ceux de 70 c'est le type
même du film à sketches il ya douze
sketches devrait la vraie comédie
italienne comme on dit vous savez la
commune italienne sur ça peut se résumer
comme cela un personnage tombe tout le
monde rit il se fait piétiner par la
foule c'est le drame
et il se relève en disant c'est la
société c'est comme ça voilà le
fatalisme italien met à la merci en tous
les cas béatrice le guen moi je mange un
très bon souvenir de panet chocolat tas
c'est un film magnifique bon voilà c'est
un jour nation italienne en europe voilà
en suisse exactement merci en tous les
cas beaucoup d'être venu nous parler
donc de ce 6e festival italien qui a
lieu au plaza du 24 mai au 1er juin
culture première
[Musique]
au moins
on
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
culture première vous avez encore
jusqu'au 5 août pas les regarder
l'exposition du photographe quand google
à l'artothèque de saint denis saint
denis elle s'intitule ma xin rouge mao
machine rouge comme on veut et l'entrée
gratuite quand google bonsoir la chine
vous connaissait bien l'afrique aussi
vous vous êtes installés chez nous
depuis quelques années où vous avez
fondé le groupe bk l on va y revenir
peut-être très rapidement compte c'est
de cette interview alors je me suis
bagarré pour trouver un bk n en fait je
finis par trouver c'est jean bernard car
google et bernard lesaint c'est bien ça
oui c'est bien ça c'est bien ça mais
alors ce soir c'est notre chine rouge
qui nous intéresse machine rouge pour ça
s'écrit avec un grand m un petit à un
grand c dans tout éco les grands
s'échine rouge c'est donc à évidemment
un double jeu de mots machine rouge et
machine rouge dans le fascicule que vous
m'avez prêté donc on parlera de la photo
tout à l'heure à l'intérieur évidemment
il ya du rouge 1 et sur fond blanc ses
marques et machines de rêve machine
douce machina ges machine unique machine
d'image machine fuyante machine
manquantes machine aveugle machine de
sable machine brillante machine
tremblante chercher le sens des choses
1987 2018 sera passé en 87 vous êtes
parti pour la première fois çi oui oui
c'est en 87 grâce à une dotation du
ministère des affaires étrangères elle
nous assure médicis à l'étranger et donc
j'ai effectué un premier séjour de
quatre mois en itinérance autour du
autour de ce cet immense pays
oui erreur vous étiez où la première
fois alors c'est une c'est une très
longue histoire évidemment puisque c'est
une histoire qui va me qui va m'occuper
pendant quasiment 3 entre 87 et 89 donc
l'année de tiananmen
et donc je vais faire très court une
histoire très longue
à l'occasion de cette dotation madani
des programmes un picto wapiti
idéogrammes est passé du pictogramme
hôpitaux idéogrammes hallyday met donc
avant de partir j'étais allé voir le
françois hébel qui était directeur des
rencontres nationales de la photographie
et je lui ai dit voilà je parle trancher
si vous voulez à l'époque la
photographie chinoise était totalement
inconnu le pays a commencé à s'ouvrir
on n'était plus dans les années de la
révolution culturelle mais on n'était
pas encore dans une ouverture comment on
la connaît aujourd'hui et donc d'une
manière générale le cinéma chinois
étaient tes pas connu les artistes
créateurs et c'est la photographie
encore moins et moi ça m'a étonné parce
que j'étais dans les années avant de
venir la réunion 89 89
gt gt à aix-en-provence j'étais très
cinéphile donc je m'intéressais au
cinéma j'ai vu ça au signalement etc
et j'avais vu plusieurs films chinois à
l'époque du studio de shanghai dans les
années 30 et c'était vraiment demander
des choses magnifiques
on peut même dire du néoréalisme avant
leur rejet dans stupéfait et donc avant
de partir je me suis il doit y avoir
quand même une un pays qui produit un
cinematic qui a des qualités là il doit
y avoir des photographes et donc
j'allais voir françois hébel directeur
des rencontres nationales de lui
expliquer le projet dubé voilà si vous
si les rencontres me paye mais mes
déplacements je veux bien aller au tour
de la chine rencontrer cette
photographie chinoise et donc je encore
je vais faire une histoire près du phare
très longue en faire une histoire très
courte
grâce aux amitiés franco chinoise qui
était à l'époque une la porte qui
permettait d'accéder d'accéder à la
chine
puisque c'est encore vrai aujourd'hui un
pour rencontrer je dirais des
professionnels il fallait passer par ce
qu'on appelle les études et les unités
de travail dont vous aviez des unités de
travail pour le spectacle vivant pour la
photographie cinéma et cetera dont une
sorte de passage obligé et grâce aux
amitiés franco chinois j'ai pu avoir un
premier contact applique un et j'avais
donc organiser mon séjour ou ce jour
quatre mois entre beijing pékin honore
jean grey quan zhu dont une grande
partie de la province chinoise de lille
et l'arrière originaire est originaire
chengdu dans le sichuan tout au sud le
pays où on mange très pimentée ensuite
j'étais monté à lhassa au tibet là
encore beaucoup d'histoires à raconter
on n'a pas le temps long mais vous posez
donc le fruit d'accords et ciani où se
trouve la fameuse armée de terre cuite
et c'est donc j'ai fait tout le tour de
la chine
et je jetterai kurek de trois anecdotes
drôles parce qu'on aime bien les
anecdotes aussi c'est que au début
effectivement j'ai pas rencontrés via
les associations effectivement comme
dans toutes les autres associations en
occident en u recettes c'est rare on y
trouvait des petits chats des paysages
colorés les soleils couchants et des
jolies filles quand il ya cet aveu pas
la seule chose qu'on nous montrait des
photographies je suis quand même
incroyable alors vers qui je vais me
tourner et je suis je me tourne vers
cinéma et vers le champ des chants des
beaux-arts il doit y avoir dansé dans
quelque chose quelque chose de ce côté
là et en dessin donc au bout de deux
mois je viens quand on y raconte on
faisait une intervention à l'école des
beaux-arts de quand on est un jeune
homme vient me voir
on sort de deux doigts et une bille
monsieur je voudrais vous montrer des
photographies mais jeudi on était en
session il n'a alors pas ici j'avais ni
de larmes en hôtel et le lendemain
effectivement des gens guerrière c'est
son nom qui aujourd hui grandes stars de
la faudra fifadji moss à ces fameux
gibault bravo vous avez une wii
le hasard a fait que j'ai rencontré un
photographe qui étaient nés le même jour
et la même année que moi zhang l'arrière
et donc il me sort ses photographies et
moi c'était plus normal et pas les
petits chats ni les soleils couchants
c'était des images à l'open flash dans
la rue très urbaine un peu un peu dans
le style de william klein dont il
n'avait jamais vu la moindre en
production et l'épisode qui a été
décisif ensuite vous verrez on va
revenir ensuite à la question de ce que
j'ai fait photographiquement là bas mais
c'est aussi lié sait que cet itinéraire
m'a emmené sur les traces de la
photographie chinoise notamment lors
d'un rendez-vous à xian ou à l'hôtel est
arrivée le représentant de l'association
des photographes chinois un jeune homme
en costume et avec deux valises remplies
de photos une valise où il y avait les
photographies de l'association depuis
une valise
il y avait ses propres photographies
tour qu'il a ouverte des petits chats
des jolies filles des paysages d'achat
etc
je mets tout ça par terre dans lé hall
de l'hôtel et puis dans cet amas de
pierres à ce qu'est ce que je vois une
pépite
mais quelque chose
j'entendis un grand artiste dans l'âme
et hélas il y avait deux images
extraordinaires notamment le choc le
cheval bondissant qui est devenu une
icône connu internationalement et je
faire très très court et décembre donc
six mois après je me suis retrouvé à
paris avec le directeur des rencontres
sale of photography plusieurs experts en
photo au directeur caméra intéressé et a
été décidé d'organiser un grand
événement sur la photographie chinoise à
partir simplement de ces deux images qui
était totalement différente de tout ce
qu'on avait vu auparavant en europe en
urs etc
alors on va faire court parce que de
temps passe vite qu'est ce qui vous
fascine dans la chine celle d'avant
d'avant ma roue celle d'après alors avec
machine rouge donc qui est un titre
n'ont pas double double sens mais un
triple un triple fond on va loin j'ai
essayé de me dire de ne pas être ni dans
une représentation à dire folklorique ni
dans une caricature de ce extrêmement
difficile de traduire une société une
société comme la chine s'est clairement
coupe évolué c'est ce que vous voulez
montrer c'est extrêmement compliqué donc
je voulais pas être dans la caricature
et est ce que j'ai et je remercie donc
car l'une de fondaumière la directrice
de l'artothèque qui m'a permis de créer
cette exposition tout coeur plus
existait mais sans cette proposition ça
serait resté dans dans mes tiroirs et
son disque dur parce qu'une partie de
films aussi est ce que donc ce que
j'essaie de traduire c'est évidemment
j'ai souvent de beaucoup d'échangés
autour de cette expérience chinoise avec
des amis ou dans d'autres contextes et
effectivement il ya la fois pour la
chine une une fascination une un attrait
comme ça c'est un pays qui fascine et en
même temps quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre de la crainte quelquefois même
quelque chose qui est dehors de la peur
et c'est vrai que on a beau nous
occidentaux beaucoup de mal à comprendre
cette société chinoise parce que c'est
chinoise a ressemble absolument rien
d'autre c'est khalid valeur de deux
cocktails et bien qu'est ce qui s'est
passé et j'avais commencé à le repérer
enfin 80 les la société chinoise avec
l'arrivée de tmt shipping
je vous rappelle la fameuse phrase de
thank you ping qu'importe que le chat
soit noir ou blanc pourvu qu'on attrape
programme s'est attrapé son écrit l'ont
attrapé la souris grâce à ce cocktail
complètement incroyable qui est un
substrat chez nous on est on est on les
marques évidemment par la part la partie
sionisme dans notre société occidentale
sont marqués par keith tennis tu les as
et bien sûr chinoise depuis 2500 ans est
marqué par par contre par la profession
passionné par confucianisme et donc ils
ont mis dans ils ont fait un mélange
donc l'officialiser évidemment comme
d'autres traditions religion philosophie
ont été balayés par les fossés culturels
mais après après le départ de mao et le
revenu des tropiques ça a été je dirais
et intégrés dans les classes sociales
voilà donc une donc c'est il ya ça dans
ce mélange
il ya je vais lui dire de cette manière
là il ya un poste maoïsme avec un
totalitarisme soft donc contrôle social
très fort
je rappelle que là ce pays d'un milliard
quatre cent cinquante millions est un
pays communiste
d'accord donc avec totalité sauf et puis
avec depuis ben azzouz de capitalisme
comme un pays et avec une dose de
capitalisme de connivence
les barons les baron rouge et noir oui
c'est tout son sens au donc vous
mélangez tout ça et c'est la chine
d'aujourd'hui donc à la fois une chine
fascinante et en même temps une chine
qui le composent interrogées alors on
pourra pas les longtemps puisqu'il ne
reste que deux minutes malheureusement
parce qu'il faut rendre l'antenne
alors moi j'étais une photo peut pas il
ya plein de photos 1 sur la vie de tous
les jours sur sur même des choses qui
traduisent le passé par exemple la dame
qui fumaient avec aux pieds bandés donc
ça ccc s'avancer et léniniste l'histoire
enseigne à ddd des jeunes avec habillés
à la mode c'est tout et puis à ce pont
que vous avez donc preuve donc qui
existe dans l'exposition à l'artothèque
ce pocket un passage entre deux 2
demandent entre la salle dans les deux
salles donc
alors j'ai regardé une fois deux fois
trois fois quatre fois se passe de
passage qui nous amène d'un côté à
l'autre de la rive du fleuve lequel
c'est pas un chinois certainement le
lion de rekem peut-être que je ne
connais pas mais débat c'était
surprenant je vous le dis quand je vous
ai rencontré je trouvais que ben c'est
ça ma je m'attendais choses plus
classiques et puis ce sont des choses
qui sont friands ce sont des vies de
tous les jours ce ccc de masse et de la
chine donne un peu de d'autrefois mais
un peu d'eau jour d'hui aussi en même
temps oui oui c'est ce que j'ai c'est ce
que j'ai ressenti tout les cas je vais
vous dire merci pour ça on pourra pas en
parler beaucoup parce que bon bah
malheureusement n'a pas le temps une
exposition donc à lui à l'artothèque
jusqu'au 4 jusqu'au 5 août
car google ca chine rouge avec donc
cette photo de ce chinois qui dort
habillée avec son pull grenat ce jeune
dans la chine se réveillèrent voilà là
le monde tremblera
alors je pense que le monde commence
déjà trembler puis si je peux me
permettre une information il ya une
exposition actuellement qui s'intitule
entre les lignes de noir et blanc qui
dure jusqu'à la fin du mois au musée
historique de villèle et qui est une
illustration en très grand format d'un
ouvrage je conseille tout le monde qui
s'intitule noir et blanc qui a été édité
donc pas l'université et par le musée un
ouvrage etc